hey I'm Nicholas be with reason TV and
today we've got a real treat we're doing
a google hangout with President Barack
Obama president thanks so much for
making time for us looking forward to it
president can you lay out your economic
program for the final two years of your
presidency nobody's going to be getting
rich they're still going to be
struggling can i call you Barack that's
fine Barack what's your biggest regret
so far you know I'm the president united
states I'm not the Emperor of the United
States the big news on Capitol Hill is
that Senator Harry Reid's a long time
Minority Leader from Nevada is stepping
down what do you think about his
retirement it's very hard to get rid of
things that don't work Barack why don't
you tell us just a big fat lie this is
the most transparent administration in
history hey Barack mr. president I'm
really glad that you shared your time
with us I know you're busy you got a lot
of countries the bomb so I just want to
say thanks so much thanks everybody make
sure to tune in next week when recent TV
interviews Vice President Joe Biden Vice
President Biden can you even count to 10
2 3 5 7 10 am i right